il y a un nom encore on pouvait parler
d'une lune de miel entre general
electric et ses sous-traitants
un festival de commandes qui avait
poussé cette pme investir dans de
nouvelles machines
les machines sont bien arrivés mais les
commandes elles ont partiellement
disparu ici un tiers de l'activité est
consacrée à general electric
une dizaine d'entreprises du territoire
de belfort seraient concernés par ce
coup de frein industriels on s'était
positionné sur des gros contrats aidés
une collaboration sur de nombreux
projets à long terme
effectivement pour certains d'entre eux
on a dû arrêter cette production est
arrêtée nos machines tout emplois créés
chez general electric permet d'en créer
un autre chez les sous traitants c'est
la règle du un pour un
alors quand le géant américain a annoncé
la semaine dernière qu'il renonçait à
créer 1000 emplois en france comme il
s'y était engagé
beaucoup ont déchanté le député du
territoire de belfort michel zoom keller
avait senti la menace est alertée
l'assemblée nationale donc avec une
grande quantité de pme qui risque
vraiment de avec une grande fragilité de
perte de l'emploi
il ya un risque de perdre emploie 2 200
à 300 emplois perdus sur le site
simplement chez les sous-traitants les
1000 emplois évaporé une trahison pour
les syndicats eux aussi avaient des
doutes depuis plusieurs mois c'était une
utopie
parce que enfin mille emplois ça se
prépare il ya des compétences critiques
il ya des apprentissages qui sont ya des
formations on n'a rien vu de ça pendant
deux ans et demi la réaction du
gouvernement n'a pas apaisé les esprits
bruno le maire ayant simplement indiqué
qu'il prenait acte de la décision de
general electric
c'est des grands naïfs moi je veux dire
on a rencontré bruno le maire il ya
quelques mois il a dit vous inquiétez
pas de givat va créer 6000 emplois bla
bla bla jeudi ils ont une confiance
encore une foi aveugle dans l'entreprise
une pénalité de cinquante mille euros
par poste n'ont créé pourrait être
imposée à general electric soit 34
millions d'euros
goutte d'eau pour l'industriel américain